The feds are suing Amazon because they say
it takes too many clicks to cancel a Prime
Membership. Reason investigated
and here's what we found out.
It took less than 30 seconds and a total
of six clicks to cancel an Amazon Prime
membership. That doesn't seem so bad but let's
put it in context. The agency suing Amazon is
the Federal Trade Commission, which is
responsible for consumer protection.
So how many clicks does it take to
submit a public comment to the FTC?
As Twitter user Patrick Hedger points out,
that's more clicks than the FTC complains
about in their lawsuit against Amazon. And
Reason's Eric Boehm noted that there's no
number of clicks you can make to get rid of
your FTC subscription. Businesses make our
lives better by efficiently delivering affordable
products through voluntary exchange. Government?
They take our money and waste it. So who would you
rather do business with, Amazon or the government?